hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and we finally
know why asta was so special all along
and what his final secret power will be
the battle between asta and lucius has
begun and lucius just revealed the truth
about his master plan his connection to
the wizard king julius and why
eliminating asta is actually his top
priority
lucius is so overpowered he is truly
someone who is worthy of being the final
villain but asta is not scared he is
ready to go and i think that we might
soon learn the truth about asta's father
so let's get into it you guys know how
this works if you want to support the
channel leave a quick like and comment
right now it helps me out a lot and if
you want to see more black lover content
in the future don't forget to subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all notifications you can also hit me
up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror finally this video will of
course contain black hover manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you've been warned in the previous
chapter we saw the fateful first
encounter between osta and lucius the
dark counterpart of the wizard king
julius this was an extremely important
moment because we already know that this
is going to be the final arc in the
black clover manga so it is practically
certain that lucius will be the final
villain of the story the moment when
asta meets lucius is the moment that he
comes face to face with the final boss
the ultimate villain and this is the
beginning of the end of the story
chapter 332 ended on that incredibly
important cliffhanger but thankfully the
very next chapter gave us many of the
big answers that we were desperately
hoping for in my previous video you will
recall that i said that i don't think
that julius was just a fake personality
that lucius made up in order to fool
everyone inside the clover kingdom
instead i thought that julius really did
exist as a separate personality but his
body was somehow usurped by lucius
chapter 333 opens up with the
explanation for what is really going on
here or at least a part of it in a
flashback from when lucius and his
siblings were much younger we learned
that lucius was born as the most
talented devil host in the history of
the zogratis family he was also born as
a very unique being because he had two
souls residing within a single body so
the fourth zogradu sibling was somehow
born with two souls similarly to william
who had the soul of the reincarnated elf
patri living inside of him and just like
with william and pottery it seems that
within the body of julius the darker
side lucius was able to take over and
it's likely that this is not the first
time that he has taken over he's
probably been taking over at important
points in time over the years that
julius has served as the wizard king
however there is no indication that
julius is some sort of reincarnated elf
so why and how was lucius born with two
souls was it just some sort of strange
birth defect or was it the result of
deliberate magical shenanigans for
instance did lucius's parents perform
some sort of forbidden magic ritual that
caused this outcome that is a
fascinating question that i hope will be
answered soon but for now we just don't
know at any rate it is clear that lucius
was extremely ambitious even from a
young age that he was very interested in
ancient magical knowledge and that he
had big plans for the future after
discovering some ancient tablets that
contained secret knowledge about
summoning devils he decided to become
the human host for asteroth the supreme
devil of time magic and lucius believed
that asteroth would provide the
important answers that he has been
searching for lucius tells julius his
other half that thanks to time magic he
has seen the future and he knows how
true peace can be achieved in this world
however it is clear that julius does not
agree with lucius's plans and that he
plans to stop him lucius knows that even
julius the one person who is closest to
him since they literally share the same
body cannot understand his master plan
he knows that julius will try to stop
him but lucius vows that he will bring
peace to this world and he will do
whatever it takes even if he has to go
against julius's wishes
back in the present asta noel and the
others are stunned to see lucius he
clearly looks like the wizard king he is
dressed like the wizard king and yet
something is different asta is the first
one to realize that this is not really
julius this is not the wizard king they
know and he asks lucius who he really is
lucius then proceeds to launch a massive
time magic spell that literally freezes
time for everyone at the ceremony and
the entire surrounding area this is the
same type of magic that julius had used
before on individual people but he had
never used it on such a massive scale
but when lucius tries to approach asta
and touch his forehead like he did to
damnatio asta jumps out of the way and
activates his devil powers lucius was
likely expecting this outcome because he
knows that asta possesses anti-magic the
ability to negate the magic of others as
a result even though everyone else was
frozen in time by lucius's time magic
spell asta was still able to move lucius
explains that he has now taken in
lucifero meaning that he has absorbed
lucifero's magic into himself austin
knows that lucius is telling the truth
because he can feel lucifero's key
inside of lucius asta demands to know
who or what lucius is and what he did to
the real wizard king lucius then
formally introduces himself as the
fourth sogratis sibling and he proclaims
that he is the savior of this world he
also says that julius is dead but let's
be real no one believes that lucius
explains that julius was on a mission
for the sake of their ideals their goal
is to create a world with no sorrow
hatred or discrimination their goal is a
world of peace true peace asta wonders
what such a vague statement even means
and lucius clarifies by saying that he
is going to fix all of mankind he plans
to destroy mankind and then ensure that
they are somehow reborn through the
magic of his siblings vanica dante and
xenon lucius claims that this will make
everyone happy and equal and to make
sure that nothing ever goes wrong again
he will personally rule over everyone as
the final wizard king now this is really
interesting because of the nature of his
siblings magic vanica has blood magic
xenon has bone magic and dante has flesh
or body magic with those three types of
magic they could presumably create
artificial human bodies so maybe that is
what lucius plans to do maybe his own
original magic is soul magic and maybe
he can transfer the souls of every human
into artificial clone bodies that would
be immortal but that would also be under
lucius's complete control that way there
would be no sorrow hatred or
discrimination because everyone would be
equal and immortal and lucius would
control all of them obviously i'm just
speculating at this point because lucius
referred specifically to the magic of
his siblings but who knows maybe his
plan will be something more like the
infinite tsukuyomi in naruto or the
human instrumentality project in
evangelion or emperor charles's plan in
code geass at any rate lucius says to
asta the same thing that he told julius
he has already seen the future and so he
has already anticipated everything there
is only one thing that he didn't foresee
and that one thing is asta himself after
all it shouldn't be possible for a life
form to be born without magic so this
means that asta is a freak of nature a
flaw of this world because asta is such
a unique anomaly and because anti-magic
is so dangerous lucius intends to remove
the flaw before it can interfere with
his plan at this point osta snaps at
lucius he tells him that he is
definitely not the wizard king because
the wizard king he knows risked his life
to save humanity and he would never want
to destroy it this is exactly what i've
been saying as well the julius we know
would never go along with lucius's plan
willingly over the course of the series
we've seen that julius really does
genuinely care about people and he is
willing to risk his life to help others
asta also says that there is no way that
someone like julius would die so easily
so he must still be in there somewhere
and asta intends to save him lucius
smiles and proclaims that he is now even
stronger than julius but this doesn't
intimidate asta he suddenly uses
anti-magic to cancel out lucius's entire
time magic spell and he vows that if
lucius really is stronger than julius
then he will surpass even the wizard
king right here and now as the text on
the final page declares that great
ambitions will be fulfilled right here
and now this epic chapter comes to an
end wow we all wanted answers and we
definitely got a bunch of them in this
chapter that said there are still a lot
of big questions to be answered like why
lucius was born with two souls why he is
no longer in a wheelchair what exactly
is his plan for humanity and so on what
do you guys think is going to happen now
does post timeskip asta stand a chance
against lucius i mean sure asta will
definitely be stronger now than he was
before the time skip but at the same
time lucius just absorbed the power of
lucifero and when you combine that with
time magic it's not gonna be easy for us
to win this one well unless anti-magic
just cuts through everything and then
it's like okay as the wind's low here's
what i'm wondering right now why was
asta born as a flaw of nature was it
just a cosmic coincidence or could it be
that someone knew that a being without
magic is the only person who can one day
defeat lucius and so asta's birth as a
being without magic was not a
coincidence at all it was actually
engineered by someone perhaps even
julius himself okay hear me out this
revelation that asta is a flaw of nature
could actually lead to the long-awaited
reveal of asta's father what if someone
who knew about lucius and his plans was
actively looking for a person who could
give birth to someone like costa and he
chose lychita because of her unique
absorption magic this person then hooked
up with lychita in order to ensure that
asta would be born and that he would be
able to one day defeat lucius what if
this person who hooked up with lychita
is none other than julius himself now
we've been led to believe that chibi
julius had no idea that lucius even
existed but maybe that wasn't always the
case based on the flashback that we saw
from lucius it seems that julius was
aware of lucius at some point definitely
when they were younger and so it's
possible that julius was secretly
working on defeating lucius all along
that is why he was always so interested
in different types of magic that is why
he went out incognito to scout talented
mages and that is why he spent so much
time studying magic julius was secretly
looking for a way to one day defeat
lucius and perhaps when he found lychita
he realized that together they could
create the man who would one day destroy
lucius together they could create asta
this would make julius osta's father and
it would also make austin's birth not a
mere coincidence but a carefully
engineered strategy for defeating the
final villain i know this is just me
speculating but we are in the final arc
of the story now so it's about time we
found out who asa's father really is
since asta appears to be the only weapon
capable of defeating lucius i wouldn't
be surprised if austa's father was
someone who had been planning to defeat
lucius for decades
and what man fits that description
better than julius himself the one who
had been opposing lucius from within him
ever since they were young oh and maybe
the reason why lucius could see the
future but he could never anticipate
asta is because julius tampered with his
time magic in order to make asta's birth
possible we now know asta's true purpose
and his secret power that has been
foreshadowed throughout the entire
series asta himself is the secret weapon
that can destroy lucius he is the only
one who can defeat him and so asta is
the key to everything the only hurdle
that he could not anticipate and again
this could be because julius messed with
time no wonder lucius took such a keen
interest in asta from the start and no
wonder lucius is so determined to remove
him as a threat as soon as possible man
we are really in the end game now and i
can't wait to see what happens next what
do you guys think are we about to find
out the true identity of asta's father
and could it be julius was osta's
existence as a flaw of nature a
carefully engineered event whose purpose
was the ultimate defeat of lucius was
julius secretly working against lucius
this entire time and if so then how does
liba fit into all of this i mean sure
the fact that asta was born without
magic is what allowed him to use
anti-magic but without coming into
contact with liba and anti-magic austin
would not have stood a chance against
lucius so if foster's birth was all a
part of some master plan then so was
asta's eventual union with libe don't
forget to let me know down in the
comments what you think about all of
these crazy developments in black clover
i always love hearing from you if you
enjoyed this video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like it
helps me out a lot and if you want to
support the channel directly for free
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications
you can also hit me up on twitter and
instagram at animeopror i want to give a
big thank you to all of our anime
outpour patrons for making videos like
this one possible special thank you to
our the one tier patrons the ones who
stand above all other clans including
alpha sigma pate heffa the toasted chi
corey mcgowan big buddhist and jeremy
pontier and i can't forget all of our
pro hero tier patrons including the one
only gilgamesh angel cruz alicia ochter
fat boy games kaido might be a duck
alivania and anime s codem if you guys
enjoy our videos and you feel that they
provide value for you consider
supporting us on patreon or here through
youtube memberships even a single dollar
helps and it means a lot to us as always
thank you guys so much for watching and
until next time see ya space cowboys